[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Rudi Zahnes auch dabei für
den Sport hallo schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Nachrichten Themen
dieses Sonntags
Umdenken in der Zuwanderungspolitik
angesichts steigender migrantenzahlen
prüft die Bundesregierung Asylverfahren
außerhalb der EU
Erdogan zurück im Wahlkampf nach
krankheitsbedingten Absagen tritt der
türkische Präsident wieder öffentlich
auf
und Doppel Triumph in Baku der Formel 1
Pilot Sergio Perez gewinnt nach dem
Sprint auch den Großen Preis von
Aserbaidschan
[Musik]
der Städte und Gemeindebund fordert
einen Neustart der Migrationspolitik der
Zustrom von Flüchtlingen müsse reduziert
werden viele Kommunen sein längst an
ihren Kapazitätsgrenzen
nach wie vor haben die Kommunen Probleme
die rund eine Million Flüchtlinge aus
der Ukraine unterzubringen dazu kommen
wieder mehr Schutzsuchende aus anderen
Ländern vor allem aus Syrien Afghanistan
und der Türkei allein bis Ende März
stellten knapp 81.000 Menschen einen
Erstantrag auf Asyl in Deutschland etwa
80% mehr als im gleichen Zeitraum im
Jahr zuvor jetzt will die SPD
Innenministerin prüfen ob schon an den
EU-Grenzen über Asylverfahren
entschieden werden könnte Ines Trams
bis zu 300.000 Migranten könnten in
diesem Jahr Asylantrag in Deutschland
stellen die Kommunen am Limit darauf und
wohl auch auf den Druck der
EU-Kommission die einen härteren Kurs
fordert reagiert nun die
bundesinnenministerin beschleunigte
Asylverfahren an der EU-Außengrenze für
Sie denkbar das geht darum dass
grenzverfahren an den Grenzen schon
Asylverfahren stattfinden können ich
glaube das ist unglaublich wichtig ist
die Registrierungen Identifizierung
bereits zum frühstmöglichen Zeitpunkt
durchzuführen damit wir eben auch offene
Grenzen in Europa nach wie vor haben
können es wäre eine neue restriktivere
Gangart der Ampel beschleunigte
Verfahren in transsitzungen bei
Ablehnung würden Migranten gleich
zurückgeschickt Skepsis bei Grünen und
Menschenrechtlern das funktionieren
nicht und verstoße gegen die
Menschenrechte
es ist ein Vorschlag der zu massenhaft
Lagern an den EU-Außengrenzen führt und
nicht dazu beiträgt dass weniger
geflüchtete kommen werden das in den
letzten Jahren gesehen diese Vorschläge
werden immer wieder gemacht auch
teilweise umgesetzt und dann gibt es am
Ende nicht weniger geflüchtete deswegen
ist das einfach nicht hilfreich wenn man
jetzt sagt wir delegieren ist an Staaten
die unsicher sind und nicht
rechtsstaatlich dann verabschiedet man
sich von dem Kernprojekt Europas und das
muss ich auch die Ampel überlegen ob sie
bereit ist Europa zu verteidigen mit
Ausnahmen will die Innenministerin den
skeptischen grünen Entgegenkommen so
sollen beispielsweise Familien mit
Kindern unter 18 weiterhin ein reguläres
Verfahren bekommen die Union kritisiert
solch mögliche Ausnahmen gerade
Deutschland ist aber hauptsielland von
Flucht in Europa und damit am meisten
belastet wir müssten eigentlich das
größte Interesse haben dass diese
Zentren kommen und auch effektiv
arbeiten die Ampel will genau das
Gegenteil sie will es entsprechend
einschränken
in anderthalb Wochen Bund Länder Gipfel
zur Flüchtlingsfrage es könnte neuer
ampelzoffen nun um Asylverfahren an der
EU Außengrenze
[Musik]
zum Tag der Arbeit morgen ist der Streit
über die Vier-Tage-Woche voll entbrannt
gefordert wird sie unter anderem von der
IG Metall auch SPD-Chefin esken könnte
sie sich gut vorstellen der
Arbeitgeberverband BDA dagegen sagt
deutlich weniger Arbeit bei vollem
Lohnausgleich sei wirtschaftlich eine
Milchmädchenrechnung und Union und FDP
fürchten eine Verschärfung des
Fachkräftemangels
eine ungewöhnliche Maßnahme plant
Bayerns Gesundheitsminister hollitschek
gegen den medikamentenmangel er will
vorübergehend erlauben in Deutschland
nicht zugelassene antibiotika-säfte für
Kinder zu importieren das sei den
Landesbehörden im Einzelfall möglich
Kinderärzte hatten gewarnt einige
Medikamente sein bundesweit so knapp das
auch für schwer erkrankte Kinder nicht
ausreichend Antibiotika zur Verfügung
stünden
Millionen haben Sie während der Pandemie
genutzt die corona-app des Bundes heute
wird die warenfunktion abgeschaltet ab
morgen ist es dann nicht mehr möglich
andere nach einem positiven Test zu
informieren und nach Begegnungen mit
infizierten eine Anzeige zu erhalten
nutzen kann man die App aber weiter für
den Nachweis elektronische
impfzertifikate
in den Sudan dort wurde die Waffenruhe
zwischen der Armee und der RSF Miliz
offenbar erneut um drei Tage verlängert
das berichtet ein milizensprecher die
Gefechte in der Hauptstadt cartoum
gingen heute ungeachtet davon weiter
immer mehr Zivilisten fliehen vor der
Gewalt mit Schiffen über den Nil ins
benachbarte Ägypten und auch die
Evakuierungsaktionen westlicher Staaten
gehen weiter ein Lichtblick für die
zurückgebliebenen ein erste-hilfsflug
des Roten Kreuzes hat den Sudan erreicht
spannend bleibt der Wahlkampf in der
Türkei erstmals nach 20 Jahren könnte es
für Präsident Erdogan richtig eng werden
wegen Krankheit hatte der 69-Jährige
jüngst mehrere Wahlkampftermine absagen
müssen doch jetzt ist er wieder da mit
heftigen Attacken gegen seine Gegner und
gegen den Westen aus Istanbul einer
Feist
er ist zurück nach dreitägiger
wahlkampfpause aufgrund einer
Magen-Darm-Grippe so heißt es besucht
der türkische Präsident am Samstag in
seinem roten Talk dem ersten türkischen
E-Auto die so sieht es Ankara größte
Luftfahrtmesse der Welt
mir geht es gut schau mich an und mach
du deine Arbeit
lasse als sonst Folgen auf der Bühne
große Ankündigungen und harsche
Wahlkampfpropaganda gegen die Opposition
unter der Führung von kilage
hat sich die Partei von Atatürk zu einem
unsfeindlich gesinnten westlichen Verein
verwandelt
Mitglieder seiner Regierungspartei AKP
bezeichneten nun gar den bevorstehenden
Wahltag als Putschversuch des Westens
diese Beschwörung eines Feindes der das
Land bedrohe
erkläre sei bekannt und bedeutet der
Präsident fürchte um seine Macht so
jetzt ist dein Dilemma es kann sein dass
er die Wahl nicht gewinnt aber er kann
auch nicht einfach gehen weil er sich
selbst als Auserwählten versteht
[Musik]
thinking
und wer sich gegen den Auserwählten
stellt ist gegen das Land so verkündet
der Präsident die Opposition
mit der Terrororganisation PKK und
weiter alle Feinde der Türkei haben sich
hinter Herrn Kemal versammelt
das am Morgen gleich mehrere kurdische
Kandidaten verhaftet werden kein Zufall
die Wahl in der Türkei wird so zur
Abstimmung zwischen Gut und Böse ob das
zieht Umfragen prognostizieren das ist
knapp werden könnte
in Israel gab es erneut Massenproteste
gegen die umstrittene Justizreform mehr
als 150.000 Demonstranten versammelten
sich in Tel Aviv sie befürchten mit der
Neuregelung werde die Demokratie
ausgehöhlt und die unabhängige
justizgeschwächtnis der Präsident
netanjahu hatte das Vorhaben im
vergangenen Monat nach massiver Kritik
zunächst ausgesetzt
in den USA ist ein schwerer Tornado über
Florida gezogen wie hier in Palm Beach
im Süden des Bundesstaates wirbelte der
Sturm Autos und trümmert durch die Luft
und entwurzelte zahlreiche Bäume
tausende Menschen waren zeitweise ohne
Strom berichte über Verletzte gibt es
nicht
zumindest das jetzt bist du dran sehr
gerne mit dem Sport in der Formel 1
entwickelt sich eine spannende Saison
zumindest gibt es ein Team internes
Duell nach dem Sprint gestern gewann
Sergio Perez heute auch das Hauptrennen
in Aserbaidschan sein Red Bull Kollege
Weltmeister Max Verstappen wurde Zweiter
Serie ist der erste der zum zweiten Mal
in Baku gewinnt Ferrari Pilot chalette
ganz links kann statt Platz 1 nicht
lange halten eine Handvoll Runden nur
dann rauscht Weltmeister Max Verstappen
an ihm vorbei und auch Peris der kurz
darauf als Verstappen die reifenwechselt
die Führung übernimmt und nach der
anschließenden
Safety-Car-Phase auch behält auf dem
anspruchsvollen engen Stadtkurs
bei einem kurzkontakt mit der Mauer hat
Perez Glück der Reifen bleibt heil der
Mexikaner holt sich seinen sechsten
Grand Prix Sieg vor Verstappen und
lecler der zum ersten Mal in dieser
Saison auf dem Podest steht schon
nächste Woche sieht man sich wieder beim
Großen Preis von Miami
der FC Bayern ist zurück an der
Tabellenspitze der Fußball-Bundesliga
die Münchner gewannen ihr Heimspiel
gegen Hertha BSC mit 2 zu 0 und haben
vier Spieltage vor dem Saisonende einen
Punkt mehr als Dortmund und Frankfurt
Fußballerinnen sind der nächsten
Teilnahme an der Qualifikation zur
Champions League ein Stück näher
gekommen die Eintracht spielte in einem
Bundesliga Nachholspiel gegen Hoffenheim
3:3 und verteidigte damit den dritten
Tabellenplatz
persönlicher Abschluss für die deutschen
Handballer im Eurocup einem
Vorbereitungsturnier für die EM im
Januar in Deutschland gegen Spanien
gewann Deutschland in Berlin mit 32 zu
31 die anderen fünf Spieler hatte das
Team von Alfred Gießler und verloren
bester Werfer heute war Juri Knorr mit
13 Treffern
das war der Sport am Sonntag danke schön
das Wetter am 1 Mai ist zwei geteilt im
Nordosten viel Sonne sonst weg sind
bewölkt dabei zunächst im Süden
nachmittags auch im Westen und in der
Mitte Schauer
örtlich Gewitter 12 bis 19 Grad
am Dienstag noch unbeständig danach
freundlich bei steigenden Temperaturen
im heute-journal um viertel vor zehn
gibt es eine Premiere Christian Sievers
befragt künstliche Intelligenz wir sagen
danke und tschüss und empfehlen jetzt
shakuntalab energy und Berlin direkt
vielen Dank Barbara Robert Habeck hat
ein Problem mit möglicher
Vetternwirtschaft CDU und CSU haben ein
Problem mit der Frage der
Kanzlerkandidatur und Arbeitnehmerinnen
und Arbeitnehmer haben eines mit sehr
unterschiedlichen Bedingungen für Arbeit
und Löhne alle drei Themen gibt es jetzt
bei uns herzlich Willkommen bei Berlin
direkt